[Music]
still has that tiny
yeah just
only in the high frequencies though
that's where it really echoes it's just
going back and forth between these walls
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome back oh what number is this
welcome to ask mkbhd version 16. this is
a once a month thing and we've gotten to
may so almost halfway through the year
and we've kept up with doing this once a
month so i asked you guys questions on
twitter what you guys wanted to know and
this is what you ask wallpaper on 8k
monitor you use in the video about the
8k monitor where can i find it so it's
actually believe it or not really hard
to find an actual genuine 8k wallpaper
so the one that you saw in the video was
a rendered out vector file for my buddy
justin mallor who's made tons of art
that showed up in my videos before it's
called ghosts 2. it showed up in
previous videos that is an actual 8k
7680 by 4320 version of that art but
it's weird even when you look on google
for things that are that exact file size
they're sometimes just like upscaled
versions of smaller files really weird
sketchy stuff from wallpaper sites so
that's where that one came from how much
difference in image quality between the
oneplus 5 and the galaxy s8 should be
expected now that oneplus is
collaborating with dxomark alright so if
you haven't already heard the hype is
now real for the next version of the
oneplus flagship killer the oneplus 5. i
don't know why they skipped four but
that's the name of the next phone and
they came out and said that they're
working with dxomark to collaborate to
make a better version of a camera for
that phone as you know dxomark is pretty
well known for just ranking objectively
the smartphone cameras that come out
year after year they even a number the
highest one we've seen recently was a 90
from the htc u11 and we've seen 89s and
88s but here's my take on that you saw
recently i've done a video just on a
blind test of the five best smartphone
cameras and the difference between those
five cameras in actual image quality was
completely random and subjective
depending on what photo you're taking
obviously some people could pick a
consistent clear favorite throughout the
entire image set but the difference in
number of points on the dxomark scale is
not that high between them so basically
what i'm saying is i think the oneplus 5
will have a pretty great camera but the
difference between that and the s8 it's
not like you can measure it it's just
also going to be pretty good what
changes should the clippers do to be
relevant in the nba they should sign a
good small forward why are ai assistants
being pushed so hard i still find
looking up information with my fingers
faster and easier well jason curry that
is actually the reason why ai assistants
are being worked on so hard because
they're still not quite better than just
typing what you want to see but small
throwback actually interviewed sundar
pichai the ceo of google a couple days
ago in the last video and something he
mentioned that same day was they're
working on ai assistance and voice
assistants to get better because that's
just the way people communicate we
naturally talk to each other and listen
to each other and respond and that's how
an actual assistant would help a person
so getting our virtual assistants to be
as close to that as possible is the end
goal they're still not there yet as you
mentioned it's still easier to usually
type what you want to see but that's why
they're getting worked on so hard is
because the ideal assistant is kind of
just like a person yo marquez 8
megapixel full frame sensor or 42
megapixel full frame sensor light versus
detail so this is the the video person
inside of me speaking i would like to
see the 42 megapixel full frame sensor
because that means i'll get high
resolution video out of it eight
megapixels i think caps me at 720p
so i mean i like low light shooting
capabilities a lot but most of the
shooting i do is not in low light so i'm
gonna go with that 42 megapixel sensor
why did you stop putting cheerios in
your videos i don't
i don't really know what cheerios are
talking about
but they're pretty subtle usually
did you cable manage your place after
linus tech came over so the thing about
cable management is
when you manage your cables when you use
cable ties and like lock them into place
that kind of implies that your setup in
that area is going to be permanent in
some way if if you organize all the
cables and lock them into place and tie
them around each other around the table
legs and everything like that then if
you ever want to change something out of
that setup that uses one of those wires
it's a huge pain in the butt to get it
out of that cable management mess so
bottom line everything that i think is
permanent in here including the insides
of computers is great in the cable
management space but everything that's a
little bit more modular or that may or
may not move or get moved out in the
next couple weeks or months or years
even
the cable management is definitely a
little less on point there your allergy
to cable ties but you can't buy a velcro
cable tie it's like the guy's never
heard of a velcro wrap will the iphone 8
be portless so assuming you mean the
next iphone that comes out in this
september is the iphone 8 i would say
probably not this year but ideally
pretty soon i guess i've said this
before for apple if the iphone goal is
to be portless and the only port that's
left since they got rid of the headphone
jack is the lightning port only thing
you use that lightning port for is
plugging it into your computer to sync
data and how often do we really plug in
to sync to itunes and charging now
wireless charging
is not really i guess where we want it
to be for a full-time only way to charge
a phone still a bit of a work in
progress so i don't see the iphone 8 now
getting rid of that last port that
people use for charging but maybe in a
year or two or a three where we have
like a sort of a radius based wireless
charging this has been talked about
where you don't have to put it right on
a pad but in a general area and it
starts to charge when we get that down
then maybe we will see a portless iphone
are you ashamed of the number of typos
you make on twitter
we can we can literally
reuse
rockets and land them back on earth
and use them again
but we can't edit tweets we could put
man on the moon
but we can't edit tweets we can build
skyscrapers
hundreds and hundreds of stories tall
and thousands of feet tall with
elevators in them that just shoot up to
the top in a matter of a minute or two
but we we can't edit our tweets we can
upload 8k videos to the internet and and
stream them and play them back on the
most ridiculously high-end machines i
have 140 terabytes over there on the
corner holding video files that i can
access at any time from multiple
computers
but i can't edit my tweets why not
huawei do you hate them okay so i see
this a lot and i i think the easiest way
to address this is i think a lot of
people who have this opinion were oh you
didn't review that huawei phone that
just came out
why do you hate huawei so much or oh i
see this a lot you didn't review the
newest sony flagship
what's with the hate for sony a lot of
people saying this are people that are
used to seeing reviews from big
companies with dozens and even hundreds
of people and they can afford to have
different people reviewing different
phones at the same time and just
churning out reviews so they reviewed
that samsung phone and that huawei phone
and that lg phone and that sony phone
and they review all that stuff but for
me i'm coming at it a little bit
different you gotta remember i'm one
person i can't review as my daily driver
four different phones at once so i don't
hate
huawei at all in fact i really like
huawei and i've showed their phones
before and i really like sony and i've
showed their phones before but i tend to
show more of the phones that i'm
personally interested in using because
that's why i review them so i'll leave
it at that uh it's been a lot of fun i
liked it a lot of the questions you guys
sent but there's a lot of exciting
videos coming up so definitely feel free
to subscribe to this channel if you
haven't already to see those when they
come out very soon thank you for
watching and i'll talk to you guys the
next one
peace
[Music]
you